three makjang who always woo we just
turn this camera on action yes hey I'm
go guys now one of my favorite things to
eat on this earth maybe not so much as a
specific cuisine but I love eating
noodles noodles is one of my favorite
carbs I'll be fed over rice and bread
any day on a previous living out loud
episode we talked about how much I love
you doll noodles but in that realm of
the Japanese world I also love Japanese
ramen if you've never had authentic
Japanese ramen and I'm not talking about
you actually flying out to Japan but
restaurants that actually do ramen in
the non Top Ramen style you [ __ ]
missing out now I'm not saying there's
anything wrong with top ramen because I
grew up on this [ __ ] and I absolutely
love it
one of my favorite things to eat on
earth is top ramen kimchi and then you
put like a cracked egg in that [ __ ]
y'all know laughing yeah yeah you do
I think ramen to me to like most kids
especially if you're Asian is a crazy
comfort food that you always had it's
like hot pockets to white people no hot
meal in a pocket see what say look at
that that is the happiest white man
you've ever seen your life and probably
saved them from a nest divorcing [ __ ]
Junaid I was gonna leave you about hot
pockets affect y'all remember that one
bug in a racist ass series of hot pocket
commercials you know hungry for girl
you're hungry for hot doctor
you're hungry for hot pocket the [ __ ]
that y'all got away with back in the day
see prior to me actually coming to LA I
never actually had real ramen before one
of the first ramen experiences I've ever
had was at this place called santoku
ramen and currently they are still my
favorite but there was this place that
open Amira's in Hollywood called Tatsu
ramen now Tatsu ramen is a very
interesting experience because it's not
like your regular sit down and dying
type of restaurant you actually order
your food on an iPad and then from the
iPad you go to the concierge is it no
it's not it's not a concierge but the
hostess takes a look at your receipt
after you paid it on the iPad and then
you sit down and they bring your ramen
now on the menu pad you get to choose
your toppings you can go for the
soft-boiled egg the bamboo shoots the
extra chopped pork you choose your broth
and the type of hardness or you want on
your noodles another bill being about
tots of two is that actually on the
table they have extra like accoutrement
that you can see a crucians and what the
[ __ ] are what the words I'm using today
when it comes to that tonkotsu broth or
the pork bone broth it's it's very
delicious I personally love it and the
noodles are great too she was just kind
of weirded me out that when I was
looking at who was making the noodles it
was this cute little white girl like
what's her job but these people give a
secret to like to go black girl that
makes noodles
that's just my type marry me baby and
you guys have been making a lot of
comments like oh don't you have a
girlfriend why I can't make joke because
I have a girlfriend huh Mariano's I love
her she ain't never gonna leave me
she's a stain on my tighty whitey no
bleach hey what's going on YouTube hope
you guys liked that episode of living
out loud where you get to see a little
bit more of my life and if you did the
[ __ ] is wrong with you but before we
sign out I want to go ahead and talk to
you guys a little bit about this thing
called fan duel now if you guys have
been watching my channel you guys know
that I have with FanDuel before and you
guys like this so we're working together
again for those y'all who don't know
listen the [ __ ] fan duel is a one-day
fantasy football league for real money
and immediate cash payouts yes there are
no season-long commitments there are no
upfront fees you could play one day any
day whatever day you want that's up do
you play now if y'all want to go ahead
and check yourselves out some FanDuel
you can go ahead and check out the link
below in the description box and of
course because me and FanDuel are
working together
guys can use the promo code David so
comedy and FanDuel will match what you
put in up to $200 if you guys have play
fantasy football before you guys know
that the only thing you guys really went
is pride but this time y'all can win
some money and if you do buy me a pony
but I will see you guys next Wendy for
some more living out loud and of course
Sunday for those vlogs don't be shy say
hi if you see me in public leave me the
[ __ ] alone playing place or say hi cuz
I'm lonely and I need a friend